reprenons du souffle et un peu de
hauteur pour rendre hommage à moers
cunningham
le chorégraphe américain présente à
partir de ce soir au théâtre de la ville
à paris une anthologie de sa
contribution à la danse moderne
une manifestation qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre du festival d'automne puisque
michel buisson directeur a été parmi les
premiers adeptes de l'américain michel
relev ici et bernard puissesseau la
jeunesse à l'époque du grand
perturbateur
ce maître de ballet est un empêcheur de
danser en rond merce cunningham
dynamique depuis quarante ans les règles
de la chorégraphie
avec lui comme jamais le mouvement est
au poste de commandement et puis
révolution la musique n'est plus le
support de la danse merce cunningham
invente de nouvelles lois musique et
danse sont créés et indépendamment l'une
de l'autre et ne se retrouvent ce soir
de la représentation
la musique est qu une chose et la danse
et autres l'est de tokyo
le temps le même temps mais ces procès
pour la musique et l'art est coupée le
temps dans ce manière différents la
musique pour tes oreilles et la danse
pour les eaux et oui et le spectateur
lui à la liberté de créer les
correspondances le vieux maître refuse
d'occuper aujourd'hui le devant de la
scène il ans préfère les marges
son dessin celle esquisse aux jeunes
danseurs brillant de prolonger le
mouvement
merce cunningham se font ton sur ton
dans le décor jusqu'à disparaître de sa
propre chorégraphie